[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICHARD WEI: Good
morning, and welcome.
My name's Richard.
JAMES BRADBURY: I'm James.
RICHARD WEI: We're
thrilled to talk to you
about a next-generation
machine learning
platform, Swift for TensorFlow.
TensorFlow is a world-leading
ecosystem for machine learning,
and we're always looking
to make it better
for all kinds of users.
TensorFlow 2.0,
available in alpha,
makes it easier than ever
to get started with ML.
But we're also looking
further beyond.
In this session, I'm
going to tell you
about a project to rethink
what a machine learning
framework could look like.
You might hear Swift for
TensorFlow and think,
this is going to
be about iOS apps.
But Swift is also a
general purpose language
that we think will help
enable the future of ML.
When figuring out what a
next-generation machine
learning platform
should look like,
we have been guided by
three fundamental goals.
First, we would
like to make sure
that every developer can be
a machine learning developer.
Second, we'd like to make sure
that every application can
benefit from the power of ML.
Third, we've seen that the
frontiers of ML research are
pushing the boundaries of a
software stack split between
Python and C++.
So we want a unified platform in
the friendly and fast language.
This is why we decided
to develop something
a little outside the box.
So we've taken the Swift
programming language,
a general purpose and
cross-platform language that
compiles to native code, and
built general machine learning
functionality right
into its core,
and combined its power with
the TensorFlow ecosystem.
And this is Swift
for TensorFlow.
Swift is a language designed
to be easy to learn and use.
Let's take a look.
Swift's syntax is familiar
and free of boilerplate.
Swift has types, so it
catches errors early for you.
But it uses type inference,
so it feels clean and simple.
Swift encourages
fluent API design.
So your code is
fluent and readable
at both the definitions
side and the call side.
Swift is open source
and has an open process
that allows us to propose new
changes, new language features
for all Swift developers.
Swift supports
prototyping platforms
such as a command line
interpreter, Jupyter Notebooks,
and Playgrounds.
Just import your
favorite libraries
and get started right away.
The TensorFlow library includes
our carefully curated Tensor
APIs, layer APIs, as well
as general abstractions
that help you build your own.
Now let's look at how to build
a deep learning model in Swift.
This is an image
classification model.
This is built out
of several layers,
forming a simple
convolutional neural network.
The call function applies
every layer sequentially,
producing a final output.
Once we have defined the
model, it's time to train it.
We start by
initializing the model
in the stochastic gradient
descent optimizer.
We'll be using random
data here, x and y.
Now we write a training
loop, apply the model,
compute the loss from labels
using the softmaxCrossEntropy()
function, and compute the
gradient of the loss with
respect to the
model's parameters.
Finally, we can
use the optimizer
to update all the differentiable
variables and all parameters
in the model.
Our layer and optimizer
APIs are inspired
by libraries like Keras, and
are designed to be familiar.
A huge part of Swift for
TensorFlow is workflow.
Lots and lots of
research breakthroughs
in machine learning come
from prototyping ideas.
Google Colab is a hosted
Jupyter Notebook environment
that allows you to
prototype your ideas right
in your browser.
A lot of researchers
and developers
use Python with
TensorFlow in Colab today.
And now we've made Colab
work seamlessly with Swift.
Now let's show you
Swift in action.
This is a Colab notebook.
As we start typing, we get
an immediate code completion.
Here we use functional
map to add 1
to each element in an array.
And it prints just
like you expect.
Now let's look at a basic
workflow in more detail.
Here's the dictionary
of numbers.
And I want to find the largest
even number in each array.
To do that, I'm using a for loop
that loops through all elements
where the element is both
greater than the largest--
than the last largest
one found and is even.
Let's run that and
see what happens.
Oops, what's wrong?
Well, it looks like Int doesn't
have a property called isEven.
No problem, let's add one.
Even though the
Int type is defined
in the standard
library, we can still
add methods and
properties to it.
In Swift, this is
called an extension.
Here we define a Boolean
computed property
called isEven, implement it in
terms of the isMultiple method.
As you can see, Swift's
syntax and naming conventions
look more like English than
other programming languages.
And now everything works.
By importing TensorFlow,
we get the power
of TensorFlow operators
as functions and methods
on a Tensor type.
Many of these
methods are the same
as they would be in NumPy
and Python TensorFlow.
Other APIs make use
of Swifty features,
like generics and
argument labels.
TensorFlow also provides deep
learning building blocks,
such as layers and optimizes.
Here's the same
simple [INAUDIBLE]
that we just showed you.
We're on GPU, and it's
running really fast.
Running the cells
train the model.
It is that simple.
So that was Swift for
TensofFlow in Colab.
Writing Swift for
machine learning
is not all that different from
writing dynamic languages.
With Colab, you can start Swift
right away in your browser,
and it gives you code
completion, free GPUs,
and you can even install a
package, using Swift package
manager, right in your notebook.
You don't have to
install anything.
It's really handy.
Next up, interoperability--
Swift interoperates
transparently with C.
So you can literally just
import a C header and use it.
But how about all
the libraries--
everybody's favorite machine
learning and data science
libraries in Python?
Do we have to read/write
everything in Swift?
The answer is, we don't.
In Swift for TensorFlow,
we have extended
Swift's seamless language
interoperability to Python.
As you start using
Swift for TensorFlow,
we want to make sure that you
didn't miss all the utilities
and libraries that
you're used to.
Now let's show you
how interoperability
works in Swift.
Python interoperability is
enabled by a lightweight Swift
library called Python.
Let's start by importing that.
Python.import lets you import
any Python package installed
with pip.
Hundreds of popular packages
are pre-installed in Colab.
Here we're going to use
NumPy and Matplotlib.
We also enable their in-notebook
visualization functionality.
Now we can call some common
NumPy and plotting functions
directly from Swift exactly
as if we're writing Python,
and it just works.
Now, OpenAI Gym is
a Python library
of reinforcement learning
environments, little games
for AIs.
Let's import that and
solve one of the games.
One of these games is
a cart-pole environment
where you train a neural
net to balance a pendulum.
We'll use a simple
two-layer neural network.
In each episode of
the game is a loop.
We get observations from
the Python environment
and call our Swift neural
net to choose an action.
After running the
game a few times,
we use the games that
went well as training data
and update our neural net's
parameters so that it will
pick better actions next time.
Repeating this process, we're
getting better and better,
higher and higher rewards.
Finally, the problem's solved.
We can also plot
the mean rewards.
As you see, you
can mix and match
idiomatic Swift code, Python
code, and a neural net defined
inline in Swift.
It is so seamless.
In fact, Python interoperability
isn't hard-coded in the Swift
compiler.
It's actually written as
a library in pure Swift.
And you can do the same--
do the same to make
your libraries--
to make Swift interoperability
work with Ruby or JavaScript
and other dynamic languages.
Now, in cutting-edge
research and applications,
people often need to dive
into low-level implementations
for better performance.
Swift's C interoperability
makes that surprisingly easy.
Importing Glibc gives you access
the C standard library from
qsort() all the way down
to malloc() and free().
Here we allocate some memory
using malloc(), store string,
and print it.
Now it's probably fair to
say that Swift in Colab
gives you a better C prototyping
experience than the C
language itself.
Now I hope you'll agree
that the best parts of Swift
for TensorFlow is how
easy it is to work
with code that is not in Swift.
And that is interoperability.
Having a few Python
libraries in hand
is incredibly useful for day
to day tasks in data science.
Swift for TensorFlow
embraces interoperability
and lets you use C and
Python without wrappers--
so seamless.
Now it's time to talk about
the dark magic in Swift
for TensorFlow, differentiation.
It is fair to say that
calculus is an integral part
of deep learning.
This is because machine
learning models are really
just mathematical functions
expressed in code.
But the special thing about
them is that we don't just
want to evaluate
those functions,
we also want to
change the parameters,
or train them by changing
their parameters based
on their derivatives.
A common technique adopted
by deep learning frameworks
is called automatic
differentiation.
Different from
traditional programming,
doing calculus in code requires
the language or the library
to understand the
structure of your code.
But who to understand your
code better than the compiler?
We think that computing
derivatives from code
is not just a simple technique,
but also a new programming
paradigm in the age
of machine learning.
So we've integrated first-class
automatic differentiation,
differentiable programming
right into Swift.
First-class
differential programming
means that native functions
like this can be differentiated.
Here's a function of floats.
You can use a gradient operator
to get its gradient function.
And just call it.
It's that simple.
And you can import
TensorFlow, of course,
to compute gradients over
tensors in the exact same way.
In fact, we've been using this
feature in the model training
examples that you just saw.
Now instead of telling you how
cool it is, let's show you.
Here's a simple
function that works
with the native
double type in Swift.
It squares x and adds y to it.
If we mark this function
with differentiable,
the compiler checks to see if
it can differentiate everything
that this function calls.
Now f is a
differentiable function.
One of the things we can do
with a differentiable function
is to get its gradient.
A gradient represents
derivatives
of the output with respect
to each of its inputs.
Here the derivatives are with--
here are the derivatives
with respect to x and y,
produced by the
gradient operator.
Well, sometimes it's more
efficient to compute the output
and the gradient together.
Here's a function that calls
the squaring function f.
We can use a value with
gradient operator to do this.
All our differential operators
like value and gradient
also work with
arbitrary closures, not
just named functions.
Here we use Swift's trailing
closure syntax to simplify it.
The closure represents the
same g function passed directly
to the differential operator.
Now so far, we've seen
differentiation on types
from the standard library
and model training examples
earlier, using differentiation
on tensors, layers, and models.
But in applications, we often
need to define custom types,
like a point, which has
an x and a y component.
Here we also define a
custom function, dot(),
that takes the dot product
of two points representing
vectors.
Now what if I call the
differential operator
on the dot product function?
Boom, Swift reports an error
at compile time saying point
is not differentiable, does
not conform to the protocol
"differentiable."
Don't worry.
This is because Swift
supports generics
and generic constraints.
The differential
operator defined
for functions whose
parameters and return type--
takes functions whose
parameters' type and return
type conform to the
differentiable protocol.
Now all we have to do is to
make the point struct conform
to the differentiable protocol.
And now everything works.
Because a gradient operator
returns a gradient tuple,
it expected two
arguments, a and b.
We can simplify the code by
using Swift's pattern matching
capability to retrieve the
tuple elements in one line.
Swift's compile-time
automatic differentiation
can also detect
more subtle errors.
Here we define a function called
roundedSum() on the point that
rounds the x and y components
by converting them, first,
to integers, then converting
the sum back to float,
back to a double.
Let's see if this function
can be differentiated.
Well, it looks like we
shouldn't have done that.
Functions over integers
are not differentiable,
because the functions
are not continuous.
And the compiler knows
exactly why and tells you.
We showed you earlier that Swift
has seamless interoperability
with C. But what happens
if I use a differential
operator on a C function?
Well, let's try that.
Let's try to
differentiate square root.
Well, it looks like it
can't be differentiated.
This is because a function
is not defined in Swift,
and the C compiler cannot
compute derivatives.
But don't worry.
Let's write a Swift function
that calls the C version
and write a custom
derivative for it.
Now, in elementary calculus,
the derivative of square root
is negative 1 over 2 root x.
We can define such a derivative
as a Swift function that
returns both the original
output and the closure that
applies the chain rule
of differentiation
to compute the derivative.
If we mark this function as
differentiating square root--
when we do this, we're
telling the compiler, whenever
you differentiate a square root,
treat the derivative function
as its derivative.
Now we can differentiate
that function.
So this exact-- this
is also exactly how
we made all the functions
and methods in the TensorFlow
library differentiable.
It is that simple.
Isn't that amazing?
Having automatic
differentiation built directly
into a general purpose
language is unprecedented.
It's a super-exciting
time to bring
your applications,
intelligent applications,
to the next level.
Differentiable programming
is new era of programming.
Language integration gives
you useful compile-time errors
and the flexibility to
make user-defined types
differential.
There's also a tremendous
amount of depth here.
But if you're interested
in learning how it works,
we have some detailed
design documentation online.
Next up-- performance.
Swift is fast.
Swift has good low-level
performance thanks
to its LLVM-powered compiler.
And it lets
programmers use threads
for multi-core concurrency.
For deep learning code, we
start with eager execution,
so writing TensorFlow
code feels great.
But the compiler
is also doing a lot
of things behind the scenes.
It's optimizing the
tensor computation,
all without changing
the programming model.
One trend we're seeing is
that deep learning models
are getting integrated into
bigger and bigger applications.
The problem is, doing
this often requires
you to export models
and treat them
as black boxes in your code.
But we think that Swift for
TensorFlow can make it better.
Because your model is
expressed just as code.
And it sits alongside the
rest of the application.
And this enables all sorts of
whole-program optimizations
that a compiler
is really good at.
It makes debugging a lot easier.
What about performance
in a research context?
Some of the most
cutting-edge projects
like DeepMind's
AlphaGo and AlphaZero
worked by bringing these
three things together.
They use deep neural nets
integrated into classical AI
search algorithms.
While it's possible for an
advanced team like DeepMind
to build all of this, we think
that an AI-first language
can make it easier.
And lowering the barriers
in the infrastructure
between deep learning and
traditional programming
can lead to new
breakthroughs in science.
The MiniGo project is a
ground-up, open source
replication of the
central advances
of AlphaGo and AlphaZero
using GCP and Cloud TPUs.
In order to achieve the best
performance from the Monte
Carlo tree search algorithm
that evaluates possible moves,
the author also had to rewrite
everything in a complex mixture
of C++ and Python.
But Swift for TensorFlow
gives you a better option.
Because MiniGo can be
written in one language
without sacrificing performance.
Let's see what that
looks like in Swift.
The Swift models
repository on GitHub
contains machine
learning models that we
built using Swift
for TensorFlow,
such as common [INAUDIBLE],,
transformer, and of course,
MiniGo.
On Linux or Mac OS, we can
build a models repository
using Swift package
manager via Swift build.
Or we can just open the IDE to
develop machine learning models
like traditional applications.
The MiniGo game has
three components--
one, the game board, two,
the Monte Carlo tree search
algorithm, three, the
convolutional model
to use with tree search.
They're all defined in Swift
code in this workspace.
Recently, we've started doing
some refactoring on the Monaco.
Now let's run some
unit tests and see
if we have broken anything.
Whoa, what's wrong?
Well, it looks like the--
if we go to the test, looks like
the shape of the value tensor
is expected to be 2, 1.
Well, where did that come from?
Let's just jump to the
definition, the prediction
method that returned it.
Well, the prediction
method simply
call self via the call method.
So let's look at that.
Now let's set a breakpoint
and run the test again
to see what's going on.
At the breakpoint,
we can print out
the shape of the value tensor
using the lldb debugger,
exactly like
application development.
Well, it looks like the
tensor has shape 2, 1,
but the test expected just 2.
To fix that, we can
simply flatten the tensor
by calling the flatten method.
Now let's drop the breakpoint
and run everything again.
Great, all tests are passing.
We could run the game
locally, but it'll
be pretty slow on a laptop CPU.
How about running it on
a free GPU in a Colab.
Let's do it.
Let's open Chrome.
And here's a Colab that's
installing the MiniGo
library that we've been working
on using Swift package manager.
And so Swift package manager
pulls directly from GitHub
and sets things up.
Now it's linking and
initializing Swift.
Here we download some
pre-trained weights using
some command line command.
And we also set up
the game environment,
like the Go board
and the players.
Now the game is
starting to play.
The stones are being
placed on the Go board one
step at a time.
Now we're running a Go
AI on GPU in the Colab.
Isn't that amazing?
To advance through
the game, here's
the same game that has been
running for quite a while.
Isn't that cool?
So that is MiniGo and Colab.
Having deep learning models sit
alongside complex algorithms
in an application and
debugging through all of them--
the dream has finally come true.
Now you've seen how a unified
programming model makes it
so easy to push the
state-of-the-art in machine
learning research.
But we want to go even further.
For example, Google is
making a major investment
in fundamental compiler
technologies, an infrastructure
that will allow you to write
custom kernels for hardware
acceleration right in Swift,
and even in Colab someday.
Now James will talk
to you about that work
and where Swift fits into
the future of the TensorFlow
ecosystem.
James.
JAMES BRADBURY: Thanks, Richard.
So this is a broad-brush
look at the lifecycle
of a TensorFlow model today.
You build a model,
typically using Python.
And then you can run it
in many different ways
on many different
kinds of hardware.
And Swift can plug right
into this ecosystem.
In fact, that's
what we're doing.
We want it to be possible to
use a TensorFlow model written
in Swift in all the places
you can use a TensorFlow
model built in Python.
But the reality is there's
a lot of complexity
here, many different hardware
back ends and compiler stacks.
And thankfully, the team is
working on a long-term project
to unify and simplify the
situation with a new compiler
infrastructure called MLIR,
or Multi-Level Intermediate
Representation.
Things like the
TFLite model converter
and compilers for specialized
hardware, all of them
will be able to
share functionality,
like source location tracking.
And this will make life
easier for everyone
in the ecosystem, all the
way from app developers
who want a better experience
like high-quality error
messages when exporting to
mobile, all the way to hardware
vendors who want to implement
TensorFlow support more easily.
Check out the TensorFlow blog
for more details on MLIR.
Now the reason I'm
bringing this up
is that MLIR is a
great opportunity
to take advantage of
the strengths of Swift
as a compiled language.
So while Python will be able
to drive MLIR-based compilers
at runtime, Swift
will also drive them
from its own compiler,
bringing benefits
like type safety
and static binaries.
In short, for users who
need the flexibility,
we can make the entire
TensorFlow ecosystem directly
accessible from Swift, all the
way down to low-level device
capabilities for writing
custom kernels, all
the while improving the
experience for everyone who
uses TensorFlow.
So that's MLIR.
Let's talk about the
original vision again.
We think Swift for TensorFlow
can help every developer become
a machine learning developer.
Thanks to Swift's support for
quality tooling like context
aware, auto-complete,
and the integration
of differentiable programming
deep into the language,
Swift for TensorFlow can be
one of the most productive ways
to get started learning
the fundamentals of machine
learning.
In fact, you don't have
to take our word for it.
Jeremy Howard's fast.ai
recently announced
that they're including
Swift for TensorFlow
in the next iteration of their
popular deep learning course.
We think Swift
for TensorFlow can
help make sure every
app can benefit
from the power of
machine learning
by bridging the gap between
application code and machine
learning code.
And we think that
Swift for TensorFlow
will provide a great
option for researchers
who need a high-performance
host language like Swift.
To break down the barriers
for you to get started,
Google Colab hosted
notebooks give you
free access to GPU resources
right in your browser.
And Jupyter Notebooks let you
quickly prototype your ideas
locally or on remote machines.
Swift for TensorFlow also
supports Linux and Mac OS
natively.
So you can use your
favorite IDE or run
the interpreter in a terminal.
RICHARD WEI: Swift for
TensorFlow's 0.3 release
is available today,
which contains
all the technologies
that powered the demos
that you just saw.
We think it's
ready for pioneers,
especially if you're running
into limits of Python
as a host language or
mixing deep learning
with traditional programming.
JAMES BRADBURY:
Swift for TensorFlow
is not yet production-ready.
But if you're excited
about what you see,
we have Colab tutorials you can
run in your browser and binary
tool chains you can
download and use.
We're actively designing and
building high-level machine
learning libraries and improving
the programming experience.
RICHARD WEI: The whole project
is developed in open source
at github.com/tensorflow/swift.
Try it out today, and we
think you're going to love it.
JAMES BRADBURY: This is
an incredible opportunity
for developers like you to help
shape the future of TensorFlow.
RICHARD WEI: Thank you for
coming, and have a great I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]